figar live bonjour bienvenue nous sommes
en direct pour vous faire vivre ce
tirage au sort ce tirage au sort de
l'euro 2024 dans un peu plus de 6 mois
maintenant du 15 juin au 15 juillet aura
lieu cette euro 2024 euh le tirage au
sort a lieu en ce moment en Allemagne il
va débuter la cérémonie a commencé
depuis un quart d'heure mais forcément
dans ces cas-là il y a toujours un peu
de folklore de concert et là il y a John
Luigi Buffon le le le grand gardien
italien tenant du titre forcément qui
est présent on va parler de ce tirage au
sort et pour en parler je suis avec
Baptiste Despré bonjour Baptiste bonsoir
Vincent bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec
nous journaliste sport au Figaro on va
suivre ce tirage au sort en direct
forcément et on va expliquer un peu
comment se passe un tirage au sort avec
les différents chapeaux vous l'avez vu
tout à l'heure chapeau 1 chapeau 2
chapeau 3 chapeau 4 Baptiste est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu
comment va marcher ce tirage au sort bah
c'est assez simple alors déjà ça va
durer une petite heure là il y a un peu
il y a eu quoi il y a eu 15 minutes de
présentation euh un petit show musical
il faut savoir que ça se passe à
Hambourg cette ce tirage au sort avec
bah finalement tout le gratin européen
qui est présent cet après-midi sauf
Didier Deschamp on y riendra tout à
l'heure mais il est absent il est excusé
parce qu'il a été opéré du dos et c'est
son adjoint Guy Stéphan qui est là pour
assister au tirage au sort donc tirage
qui devrait durer à peu près une petite
heure il y a 11 anciens champion
d'Europe de toutes nationalités
différentes qui vont Procé au tirage au
sort donc on a vu notamment on on a vu
bouffon et il y aura d'autres somités du
foot européen qui seront là et vous
l'avez dit Vincent donc c'est assez
simple le tirage au sort c'est qu'il y a
quatre chapeaux chapeau 1 chapeau 2
chapeau 3 chapeau 4 euh l'euro qui aura
lieu du 14 juillet du 14 juin pardon au
14 juillet en Allemagne l'été prochain
il y a six équipes par chapeau on le
voit là sur le petit tableau que que
vous avez derrière nous donc les
Français sont dans le chapau 1 en
compagnie de l'Espagne l'Angleterre
l'Allemagne la Belgique le Portugal ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire ut dire que
ces six équipes là ser s'affronteront
pas au premier tour et après donc
chapeau 2 avec six équipes idem chapeau
3 et chapeau 4 aussi sur les 24
qualifiés on en connaît aujourd'hui au
moment où on se parle 21 il y en a trois
autres qui seront connus au mois de mars
à travers des barrages c'est assez
complexe on va vous épargner un petit
peu tout ça mais en gros c'est un petit
tableau et et on saura finalement le
trois nom des derniers derniers lauréa
mais ce soir il y aura le tirage au sort
et il y aura notamment trois
incertitudes avec ces trois ces trois
futures équipes mais pour le reste
l'équipe de France sera fixé sauf si
elle tombe euh sur une de ces équipes
barragistes à 100 % sur sur ce qui se
passera l'été prochain en Allemagne et
on vous expliquera forcément tout ça
vous voyez dans le chapeau 4 il y a
trois équipes avec des petits points
d'interrogation et quatre équipes
différentes voilà ce sont ça c'est cela
les barrage Baptiste j'ai envie de poser
quand même une question assez rapidement
mais est-ce que la France est à 6 mois
de la compétition le favori de cette
compétition bah au moment où on se parle
tout le monde a enfin personne n'a envie
de rencontrer l'équipe de France au
premier tour parce que c'est la
meilleure équipe d'Europe Europe une des
meilleures équipes du monde on se
rappelle il y a il y a à peine un an
l'équipe de France était finaliste du
Mondial contre l'Argentine ils sortent
d'une très belle année en en 2023 avec
une seule défaite contre l'Allemagne au
mois de septembre en amical c'était
l'équipe B sinon ils ont survolé leur
phase de groupe en éliminatoire de de
l'euro donc oui personne veut affronter
la France la France au moment où on se
parle parce que did Deschamp le dit
souvent et c'est vrai la vérité
d'aujourd'hui comparé à celle de du mois
de mai il peut y avoir beaucoup de
choses il suffit qu'un k Mbappé se
blesse et là c'est plus du tout la même
équipe de France on va rester optimiste
au moment où on se parle oui l'équipe de
France est la grande favorite de cette
euro et derrière on peut placer quand
même l'Angleterre qui a une très belle
équipe aussi euh l'Allemagne c'est plus
compliqué le Portugal est aussi en en
grande forme ils ont survolé leurs
éliminatoires également donc je pense
que c'est France en 1 et puis après
Angleterre Portugal et puis après on
retrouvera tout ce qui est Espagne
Belgique et les les les finalement les
candidats au titre habituel h il y a
fnaf dans les commentaires qui nous
parle des Belges euh les Belges qui
sortent d'un d'une coupe du monde qu'on
va dire plutôt raté ça devait être leur
grande coupe du monde pour la la fin de
leur génération dorée euh aujourd'hui
les Belges sont pas dans les plus grands
favoris mais ça reste quand même
toujours une équipe très très dangereuse
bien sûr ça reste une équipe dangereuse
qui est habitué au aux grandes
compétitions internationales ils ont
changé d'entraîneur mais il y a toujours
bon il y a plus il y a plus Eden Hazard
qui qui a qui a arrêter sa carrière mais
mais on reste quand même sur une sur une
très grande équipe avec courtois
notamment il y a du Lukaku enfin il y a
quand même des grands noms encore en
Belgique et alors je dis pas qu'il
faudra compter sur eux sur le sur le
titre au mois de juin et encore que mais
en tout cas ils font partie des
outsiders ils sont pas dans les grands
favoris les belges mais ils font partie
des des outsiders preuve en a ils sont
dans le chapeau 1 parce que si on va un
petit peu plus loin que les les chapeaux
1 dans le chapeau 2 il y a quand même
une équipe comme comme le Danemark dans
le chapeau 3 on retrouve on retrouve les
Pays-Bas et la Croatie les Croates on
les présente plus c'est quand même un
petit pays mais ce qu'ils font depuis
plus de 10 ans sur le la chaîne les
chiqu pardon du football mondial
européen c'est assez extraordinaire ils
seront encore là et puis redouter
redoutable à l'euro la France voudra pas
notamment les avoir lors de ce premier
tour et puis le chapeau 4 l'équipe à
évité c'est l'Italie alors l'Italie
passe par un trou de souris ils étaient
pas la dernière Coupe du monde mais ils
son ils sont tenants du titre c'est eux
qui ont gagné en 2021 qu' on battu
l'Angleterre en finale cétait manchini
l'entraîneur c'est c'est plus lui
aujourd'hui mais c'est Spaletti mais
mais on va vouloir aussi côté français
éviter l'Italie parce que euh ça reste
quand même délicat et ça reste un très
grand nom du football européen et
mondial oui effectivement ils ont raté
les deux dernières éditions de La de la
Coupe du monde ils ont gagné l'euro
c'est les tenant du titre mais pour
autant à chaque fois les qualifications
sont dans l'impression que c'est très
compliqué ils sont encore qualifiés dans
les derniers instants face à l'Ukraine
il me semble oui non mais c'est c'est
très compliqué pour l'Italie parce que
le souci c'est qu'ils ont pas ils ont
pas réservoir colossal que ce soit dans
quasiment tous les secteurs de jeu c'est
pas comme la France et et on évoquera
les les Français tout à l'heure mais
mais mais l'Italie ils ont pas notre
réservoir ils ont pas des attaquants du
milieux de terrain dès qu'il y en a un
qui se blesse il y en a un autre qui
arrive ils ont du mal à s'exporter aussi
il y a pas il y a pas énormément de
joueurs italiens qui qui brillent à
l'étranger donc c'est plus un problème
générationnel côté côté italien ils ont
fait un un euro mais extraordinaire et
au-delà de leurs attentes finalement il
y a maintenant plus de 2 ans parce que
personne donnait l'Italie victorieuse et
l'Italie ils ont gagné l'euro mais
c'était pas non plus une génération
fabuleuse on l'a vu parce que derrière
il se casse la figure ils seront là à
l'euro euh les é prochain en Allemagne
mais mais mais en revanche pour compter
sur eux sur la victoire finale il faut
être italien pour parier sur sur la sur
la Squadra parce que ça reste d'
délicats quand même pour pour ce
jusqu'en demi-finale voire en finale on
a dans les commentaires quelqu'un qui
nous parle de l'Allemagne HTI qui qui
nous dit l'Allemagne alors l'Allemagne
qui est championne du Monde U17 depuis
depuis aujourd'hui ils ont battu la
France penalty voilà au tir au but
justement l'Allemagne qui qui a quand
même beaucoup de mal ces derniers temps
alors alors que ils ont pour eux aussi
un réservoir assez incroyable mais pour
autant ils n'arrivent pas vraiment à à
faire marcher leur équipe on a
l'impression oui il sont en grande
difficulté alors ils ont battu les ils
ont battu les Français quand même au
mois de septembre c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure en préambule alors certes
c'était c'était au cours d'un d'un
rassemblement où Didier Deschamp avait
énormément fait tourner en en Allemagne
on y était à à Dortmund pour ce match
c'était l'équipe B voir l'équipe C de de
de l'équipe de France les Allemands flic
a a été vincé anti flic l'ancien coach
du du Bayern Munich il a été remplacé
juste sur ce ce match par Rudy voler
l'ancien attaquant notamment de
Marseille et qui est directeur sportif
en Allemagne au sein de la fédération et
ils ont changé à nouveau d'entraîneur de
sélectionneur donc c'est nagelsman que
tout le monde connaît sur le la chaîne
lchiqu pardon du football européen avec
avec le Bayern Munich ils repartent sur
un nouveau cycle après encore une fois
les Allemands les Allemands à domicile
il faudra pas non plus dire que c'est
facile que il faut absolument tomber sur
eux on sait pas ce qui peut se passer
nagelsman a encore quelques mois devant
lui pour reconstruire une équipe ils
peuvent arriver en opération commando
chez eux devant leur public et ça reste
un un nom immense du du football mondial
même si sur les dernières Coupe du Monde
c'est compliqué eux aussi en terme de
génération c'est c'est plus dur ils ont
pas d'attaquants qui brillent au niveau
international ils ont des joueurs je
pense à Thomas Müller qui est toujours
là mais à kimic qui sont un peu dans le
dur
donc c'est c'est difficile pour
l'Allemagne ils sont à des années
lumières du du du de la grande tion que
c'était mais en revanche il faut il faut
faut pas dire que c'est terminé pour eux
parce que personne voudra tomber
notamment dans ce tirage au sort je
pense au Pays-Bas ou à la Croatie s'ils
peuvent éviter l'Allemagne ils s'en
préveront pas aujourd'hui effectivement
parce que on l'a vu aussi il y a 3 ans
lors de l'Euro 2020 mais finalement 2021
la France é tombé dans un groupe
extrêmement relevé avec l'Allemagne le
Portugal et la Hongrie alors ce ne sera
pas le cas cette fois-ci puisque
forcément l'Allemagne et le Portugal
sont dans le même chapeau que la France
mais il y a il y a il il y a toujours
cette question de pas commencer la
compétition trop forte pour garder des
forces pour la suite ben vous avez tout
résumé Vincent et c'est ça finalement la
la complexité de la de la chose et de ce
tirage au sort si on se si on reste nous
franco-fançais un peu chauvin côté
équipe de France ils veulent absolument
un premier tour assez abordable on va
dire pour rester poli tous les
entraîneurs tous les sélectionneurs
veulent ça ça c'est pas une nouveauté
c'est pas un scoop mais mais en revanche
le fait d'être dans le chapeau 1
finalement on l'a dit ça vous évite de
tomber quand même sur l'Angleterre la
Belgique Portugal Espagne et Allemagne
ça c'est important et Didier Deschamps
se souvient notamment du du dernier Euro
où vous l'avez dit Vincent ils étaient
avec avec l'Allemagne avec le Portugal
avec la Hongrie ils ont bataillé pendant
ces trois premiers matchs ils ont perdu
beaucoup de plumes ils ont fait une
victoire et de nul ils sont sortis de ce
groupe là on se disait notamment
rappelez-vous c'était il y a pas si
longtemps mais ça paraît déjà loin il y
avait Karim Benzema aussi dans dans
cette équipe de France on a débarqué
avec Benzema Mbappé Griezmann on s'était
dit bon bah c'est bon c'est plié on va
être champion d' Europe et au final
l'équipe de France sort de ce premier
tour très difficile physiquement c'était
c'était rude parce que on se souvient
d'un match contre la Hongrie en plein
canère à 15 16h où les Français ont
perdu beaucoup de beaucoup de jus et ils
sont arrivés en 8e de finale ils sont
fait cueillir ils ont perdu contre la
Suisse notamment au tir au but on s'en
souvient tous de ça ça reste un immense
échec et sans doute le plus gros échec
de did deschan en équipe de France donc
pour cette raison ils sont très heureux
côté français de figurer dans le chapeau
1 et de pouvoir on va voir parce que
parce que on peut après aborder dans
dans les questions suivantes le pire et
le meilleur tirage côté français mais
mais si vous affrontez le Danemark les
Pays-Bas et l'Italie bah ça sera pas un
premier tour facile en revanche si si
vous avez l'Albanie ou la Slovaquie plus
un un barragiste là ça vous permet mine
à rien de de rentrer assez
tranquillement dans votre dans votre
compétition et et sans sous-estimer
personne mais mais en tout cas c'est
c'est plus abrordable h alors là nous
avons en ce moment la simulation
forcément on peut pas vous montrer les
images du tirage au sort puisque nous
n'avons pas les droits mais on va vous
faire vivre ne vous inquiétez pas et
puis vous pouvez nous vous nous poser
vos questions on y réponditude avant que
le tirage au sort commence on va se
pencher effectivement sur le meilleur et
le pire tirage Baptiste selon vous ce
serait quoi bah le le meilleur le pire
tirage pour l'équipe de France c'est ce
que je disais c'est bah c'est affronté
le Danemark on a toujours un peu des
difficultés même si dernièrement quand
même on est largement au-dessus des des
Danois qui sont dans le dans le chapeau
2 ça semble être la formation finalement
la plus la plus costaud dans ce chapeaul
chapeau 3 il y a kifkif entre entre les
pays bas qu'on a affronté en en phase de
poule des éliminatoires on a battu deux
fois notamment une belle victoire là-bas
mais il faut quand même se rappeler et
recontextualiser c'est que l'équipe de
France a affronté deux fois une équipe
des Pays-Bas très amoindrie avec
beaucoup d'absen donc au mois de juin on
aura pas la même équipe des Pays-Bas en
face de nous je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
la Croatie dans le chapeau 3 c'est aussi
compliqué donc il y a match entre
Pays-Bas et Croatie et puis bien sûr
comme on l'a dit il y a quelques
secondes l'Italie il faut éviter
l'Italie donc oui le pire tirage ce
serait ça ce serait danemarque Pays-Bas
au croattie et Italie après la Suisse
dans le 4e c'est pas forcément très
facile non plus parce qu' ça pas B
souvir facile et surtout et puis non
c'est pas un bon souvenir mais alors
après on est on est normalement
largement meilleur que les Suisses mais
mais c'est eux qui nous ont qui nous ont
fait tomber en 8e de finale de l'Euro il
y a il y a 2 ans et et et oui il faut
après à choisir je préfère prendre les
Suisses que les Italiens oui c'est sûr
et le et pour le meilleur tirage alors
qu'on découvre la mascotte on peut pas
vous le montrer forcément mais une très
très belle mascotte qui vient d'arriver
sur le
plateau et pour le meilleur tirage bah
pour le meilleur tirage ce serait dans
le chapeau 2 tomber contre contre
l'Albanie qui est quand même une une
petite nation au niveau européen après
je pense qu'il y a aussi match entre
l'Écosse et la et la Slovaquie en en
chapeau 3 et puis après tomber sur sur
un barragiste alors ça peut être il y a
différentes possibilités on peut on peut
tomber contre contre la Grèce qu'on a
joué là en éliminatoire de de l'euro ça
fait beaucoup de suppositions parce
qu'en fait ils sont dans un petit
tableau un mini tableau les trois trois
bar riste et à l'issue de celui-ci on
aura les trois noms mais ça peut être
aussi le pays de gale la Finlande
Pologne Estonie enfin on n'est quand
même pas sur le gratin du du football
européen pour ses pour ses barrag si si
dans le chapeau 4 on évite l'Italie et
une moindre mesure la Suisse on est
quand même assez verni effectivement et
on verra ce que ça donne alors
l'Allemagne vient d'être tiré mais
c'était protocolaire puisque l'Allemagne
on sait déjà ils seront dans le groupe a
dans le groupe a dans le groupe 1 en
fait ce qui va se passer là c'est que
les les les équipes vont être tiré et ce
qui va être choisi aussi c'est leur
place dans le groupe ce qui concerne
uniquement une chose c'est de savoir
contre qui ils vont jouer et dans et et
dans quel ordre exactement alors et puis
il faut savoir sur les spécificités
quand même de de championnat d'Europe en
Allemagne
euh déjà donc 24 équipes on l'a dit il y
a 21 qualifiés aujourd'hui trois
baragistres au mois de au mois de mars
six groupes de six groupes de quat la
répartition dans ce dans le championnat
d'Europe qui dans un seul pays ce qui
est important à dire par que le dernier
était quand même un peu partout en
Europe les prochaines Coupes du monde
seront dans différents pays donc c'est
assez rare maintenant pour être souligné
ça va être uniquement en Allemagne ce
championnat d'Europe et euh et après au
niveau des des groupes tuur des
répartitions par zon géographique avec
trois zones différentes la zone nord la
zone ouest et la zone sud donc la zone
Nord notamment ce sera Berlin lebchic
euh après la zone ouest il y aura
Dortmund il y aura Dusseldorf il aura
Cologne et et après zone sud avec
notamment Munich et et stutgart les
français pour être un petit peu dans les
dans dans les coulisses de de tout ce
qui se passe c'est que ils aimeraient
notamment être dans la zone ouest euh
avec du côté Dortmund Cologne après on
verra la France c'est côté bah il y a il
y a de ça bon ça eux entre guillemets il
ils s'en fichent un peu mais c'est
surtout au niveau des des camps de base
ça c'est ultra important pour le grand
public on s rend pas compte c'est
toujours c'est toujours une grande
grande question exactement c'est
déterminant parce que ça peut jouer sur
la suite finalement des installations à
la fois de votre hôtel à la fois de des
terrains d'entraînement que vous avez à
disposition il faut savoir que les
Français ça a été compliqué notamment en
période covid en 2021 il y a eu des des
tensions en interne sur le choix des
établissements une ouverture pour
certaines nations auprès de leur famill
pour voir après les matchs femmes
enfants copains copines et sauf que côté
français tout était fermé bref ils ont
un mauvais souvenir de ça à la fois sur
le côté sportif et sur le côté vraiment
coulisse donc l'équipe de France une
fois que le tirage au sort sera effectué
ce soir vous pouvez être sûr que les
Bleus ils vont se ruer sur les
différents stades d'entraînement et
hôtel qu'ils ont préalablement visité
depuis quelques semaines à la fois le le
chef de la sécurité à la fois pas Didier
Deschamp en personne mais mais tout ce
qui est personnel du du staff euh pour
le côté technique opérationnel ils ont
fait leur petit tour en Allemagne en
gros ce qui se passe c'est qu'à chaque
fois que vous êtes qualifié vous avez un
catalogue de l'UEFA ou la FIFA là pour
le coup c'est européen donc c'est l'UFA
et qu'on voit ça aux différentes nations
en fonction des zones qu'on a qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure et et et après
charge aux équipes de se déplacer de
voir ça je préfère ça pour le terrain ça
je préfère ça pour l'hôtel et et donc ça
c'est euh c'est ultra important donc dès
que le tirage sera terminé et ben
l'équipe de France se ruera sur tel ou
tel établissement voilà prier première
équipe tiit l'Espagne l'Espagne qui est
parti euh dans le groupe B alors pour
l'instant on place les équipes on
regarde un peu euh où est-ce qu'elles
vont aller euh donc l'Espagne on en a
pas trop parlé de l'Espagne aussi euh
une équipe jeune qui sort aussi d'un
Mondial plutôt catastrophique
oui l'Espagne c'est c'est en fait ce qui
est assez finalement ce qui se retrouve
dans dans dans un peu toutes les les les
nations sauf peut-être au Portugal et en
Angleterre c'est le côté générationnel
où où où il y a des fois forcément on
pense à l'équipe de France nous on est
quand même des chanceux parce que on a
un réservoir qui est colossal mais c'est
pas le cas de tout le monde on souvient
de l'Espagne bien entendu qui avait
marché sur sur l'Europe et sur et sur le
monde au début des des années 2010 on se
souvient qui sont double double champion
d'Europe en 2008 2012 les Espagnols
c'était une immense équipe de de
football alors attention on n'est pas 2e
division européenne non plus hein mais
mais l'Espagne oui c'est ça restera
quand même un un gros morceau alors
l'Angleterre qui est allé dans le dans
le groupe C et maintenant c'est la
France c'est la France qui est tirée et
on va savoir dans quel groupe va aller
la France puisque on le disait on va
pouvoir vous dire même maintenant ils
vont aller dans le groupe D l'équipe de
France sera donc dans le groupe D et
dans le groupe D je suis en train de
regarder nous allons jouer euh a priori
à Hambourg dusüseldorf Berlin leipsich
euh Berlin et Dortmund selon les alors
exactement exactement donc on est dans
la zone ouest là donc on est dans la
zone dans dans la zone ouest ouais
exactement parce qu'il faut savoir sur
cette euro c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure alors ça se présente comme un un
euro écologique aussi à savoir que donc
il y a des répartitions par zone et les
équipes nationales ont l'obligation euh
notamment de d'effectuer deux de leur
leurs trois déplacements au premier tour
en train ou en quart et ça c'est c'est
important c'est une des spécificités de
de cet Euro quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
tous les déplacements que ce soit des
des sélections des clubs les tournées en
Asie en Amérique du Sud Amérique du Nord
sont assez décriés c'est une des forces
et et ce qui a fait que la candidature
Allemagne allemande pardon a été choisie
c'est ça c'est notamment pour le côté
écologique et et donc l'équipe de France
comme toutes les autres sélections
nationales devra effectuer deux de ces
trois premiers dé Clement en car ou en
ou en train et donc la Belgique s'est
retrouvé dans dans le groupe E il y a il
y a aussi des choses qui sont faites
aussi pour les pour les supporter pour
qu' qui vont avoir accès à à des
transports en commun et le Portugal qui
est dans donc dans le groupe F alors
déjà donc là on a donc les les les
premiers le chapeau he qui est qui est
tiré on va y voir plus clair maintenant
ça va ça va défiler donc on va faire le
on va faire le groupe B en tout cas le
chapeau B et ainsi ainsi de suite voilà
moment chapeau on est en train de voir
toutes les équipes donc c'est la Hongrie
la Turquie la Roumanie le Danemark
l'Albanie l'Autriche on parlait de
l'Albanie équipe a priori facile on se
rappelle qu'on avait joué contre eu en
2016 et que ça avait été assez compliqué
en certain Dimitri paayette nous avait
fait beaucoup de bien en fin de match
exactement heureusement que Dimitri
paayette qui aujourd'hui joue joue au
Brésil nous avait un petit peu sorti du
du piège mais c'est aussi ça le le
championnat d'Europe c'est c'est qu'il y
a quand même des nations qui sont
d'apparence comme ça qui font parti de
la 2uxè division mais là on est quand
même sur déqualifier les les 21 après on
va pas se mentir l'Albanie si on tombe
sur eux c'est c'est pas non plus c'est
pas non plus un foudre de guerre et je
pense que l'équipe de France sera sera
suffisamment satisfaite mais là donc on
a la présentation oui de de toutes les
sélections du du du chapeau 2 et encore
une fois si on devait pour l'équipe de
France éviter quelqu'un une une nation
c'est c'est plutôt le Danemark parce
qu'après vous avez l'Albanie la Roumanie
l'Autriche la Turquie la Hongrie alors
on se souvient la Hongrie on avait aussi
eu des des difficultés au au derniers
EUR parce que ils étaient à domicile
parce que match en en plein canère je me
souviens j'y étais pour pour Le Figaro
donc c'était quand même un moment
difficile pour pour l'équipe de France
vous avez énormément souffert mais mais
là aussi si s'il y avait à choisir entre
la Hongrie et et le Danemark le staff
des Bleus notamment gu Stéphan qui est
aujourd'hui présent en hourg je pense
qu'il signerait il signerait tout de
suite effectivement avec la la Roumanie
alors c'est c'est la Hongrie qui a été
qui a été tiré en premier vous en parlez
la Roumanie équipe qui a été quand même
qui est sortie invaincu de de la de ces
matchs de qualification équipe qu'on
connaît assez peu je vais pas vous poser
beaucoup de questions sur les joueurs
qui jouent à Romanie btiste de vous
inquiétez pas alors la Hongrie ils vont
aller avec l'Allemagne la Hongrie va
jouer donc contre l'Allemagne il se
retrouent donc puisque ils étaient déjà
dans le même groupe au dernier Euro
exactement et je pense que les Allemands
sont sont contents aussi d'avoir les les
Hongrois dans leur dans leur poule tout
en évitant le le Danemark et là ça su
pour les pour le chapeau 2 c'est
l'Albanie qui est tiré je voulais
regarder le résultat du match
euh de Hongrie Allemagne ça avait donné
deux buts partout de buts partout donc
pas forcément un très très bon souvenir
pour les Allemands l'Albanie l'Albanie
qui va donc aller dans le groupe B avec
l'Espagne donc c'est l'Espagne qui a le
tirage entre guillemets plus favorable
pour euh pour ce pour ce pour ce groupe
c'est le Danemark qui est qui est qui
est tiré ensuite le Danemark qui semble
du coup aller plutôt avec l'Angleterre
puisque on a l'impression qu'en fait ils
suivent les voilà c'est ça en fait c'est
ils suivent les les différents enfin
pardon excusez-moi ils sont tirés et ils
vont dans le premier groupe qui est
disponible pour eux et donc ce sera le
groupe C et donc nous aurons Angleterre
face au Danemark il me semble qui
s'était joué jou aussi lors du dernier
et ça ça commence à être à être costaud
quand on voit Angleterre et et Danemark
dans le dans le même groupe ça promet
déjà une une belle affiche au premier
tour demi-finale du dernierre EUR
exactement non non c'est c'est c'est
c'est très intéressant comme tirage ça
permet aussi Paris cocher au bleu de de
les éviter mais mais le Angleterre
Angleterre Danemark déjà va être une des
premières affiches de de ce premier tour
de de l'euro l'été prochain et ce sera
l'autrich l'Autriche l'Autriche pour la
France alors Autriche qui a battu
l'Allemagne il y a peu qui est une
nation alors on connaît David Alaba par
exemple qui est qui qui est un très
grand joueur mais il y a aussi une une
bonne génération on va dire de de
joueurs Autrichiens ouais l'Autriche non
non mais l'Autriche regardais justement
je voulais juste vérifier leur leur
classement au classement au classement
FIFA
mais on est quand même content côté
français he j'ai pas eu j'ai pas vu la
caméra le le plan fixe sur sur gu
Stéphan mais il respecte l'Autriche bien
bien entendu mais plutôt plutôt que de
de oui de d'affronter le le Danemark
l'Autriche oui je sais ça ouais 24e
nation au classement FIFA entre la Corée
et l'Australie on est quand même pas sur
des foots de guerre si on peut se parler
un peu franchement Vincent on va se dire
les choses l'Autriche est plutôt correct
pour premier tour la France on devrait
facilement les passer Belgique face à la
Roumanie la la Roumanie qui était donc
tiré dans le groupe E et c'est la
Turquie la Turquie qui est qui qui va
dans le groupe F du Portugal alors dans
dans ce chapeau 2 on a l'impression que
alors il y avait des favoris et des des
équipes à prendre des équipes à éviter
mais il y avait pas forcément un grand
un grand écart de niveau par contre
c'est le chapeau 3 où on a l'impression
vu qu'on a le Pays-Bas et la Croatie
d'un côté la Slovaquie et l'Écosse de
l'autre il y a un peu plus de différence
de niveau on a l'impression quand même
ouais le chapeau 3 on a vraiment quand
même des alors à la fois sur le côté
footballistique on a aussi comme vous le
disiez avec avec l'cosse notamment ses
supporters mais non mais Pays-Bas
Croatie c'est quand même un tout autre
niveau euh que le que toutes les nations
qu'on a pu voir dans le dans le chapeau
2 mais euh on a hâte de voir un petit
peu la suite regardez là la Belgique
avec la Roumanie et là ça va être avec
le Portugal c'est ça c'est ça Turquie
Turquie face face au Portugal la Turquie
qu'on attendait lors du dernier rut ça
devait être l'équipe surprise on nous
l'avait vendu et ça c'était assez mal
terminé pour eux aussi on s'en souvient
assez rapidement ils avaient fait ils
avaient fait le match d'ouverture et je
crois d'ailleurs ils étaient avec
l'Italie pourinstant on s'en sort pas
trop mal Vincent là on va passer au
chapeau 3 mais on s'en sort pas trop mal
ouais on s'en sort pas trop mal alors on
a qu'une seule équipe pour l'instant si
on prend les Pays Bas on prend l'Italie
ça ça ça changera assez vite
aprèsement la finalité sera plus la même
c'est pas pour défendre le le manque
d'angeju aussi mais on en a pas parlé
encore mais c'est pas les deux premiers
qui passent c'est presque les trois
premiers puisque c'est les quatre
meilleurs trè donc même si on est dans
un groupe dur euh il y a un peu il y a
pas beaucoup d'équipes qui sortent au
premier tour en fait bah en fait c'est
ça un peu le le côté bah vous élargissez
finalement le l'euro donc forcément
derrière il y a des modalités de
qualification qui sont différentes je
trouve que ça perd de son sel et et de
sa saveur au premier tour avec des
matchs qui sont un peu plus un peu plus
délicat mais mais franchement oui si
vous êtes éliminé dès le premier tour de
l'Euro avec ces modes de qualification à
savoir les quatre meilleurs 3è bon les
deux premiers ça c'est sûr c'est que
vous avez pas grandchose à y faire
surtout quand on s'appelle l'équipe de
France mais mais oui il y a une marche
d'erreur qui est déjà quand même assez
conséquente vous pouvez vous pouvez vous
vous rater entre guillemets sur les
premiers matchs ce sera pas l'objectif
de de l'équipe de France et et de Kyan
Mbappé et toutes ses partenaires mais
mais très
sincèrement pour pas se qualifier pour
la suite c'est ce serait vraiment un
fiasco côté côté équipe de France c'est
certain alors l'Allemagne qui hérite de
l'Écosse l'Allemagne à domicile qui pour
l'instant hérite d'un groupe qu'on va
qualifier de plutôt facile oui alors à
sa pororttere alors après les Allemands
je pense que là-dessus ils vont pas non
plus s'enflammer parce qu'ils sont
tellement mal ils ont perdu comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure ils ont ils ont
changé de sélectionneur flic a été
remplacé par à la fois voleur et surtout
par nagensman il a il y a quelques mois
c'est une équipe qui est sur le déclin
qui est à la recherche de résultat de
dynamique certes ils seront ils seront
devant leur public les Allemands mais
mais je pense et c'est certain même ils
vont pas arriver comme des conquérentss
au premier tour on regarde leurs
résultats récents ça c'est certain alors
bonne nouvelle l'un des premiers gros de
ce japau 3 est passé c'est la Croatie et
qui va aller du côté du groupe B donc
Croatie Albanie Espagne on aura un très
beau choc Croatie Espagne dans ce groupe
bah on avait on avait le le plus beau
choc entre l'Angleterre et le Danemark
jusqu'à maintenant et au premier tour
maintenant on a espagnecroatie c'est
vraiment le plus beau choc de de ce
premier tour de de championnat d'Europe
parce que les Croates on le sait ils
nous ont posé énormément de de
difficultés c'est un petit pays hein la
Croatie on se dit la Croatie c'est
finalement normal de les voir voir comme
ça aussi souvent en quart de quart de
finale demi-finale on se souvient Coupe
du Monde 2018 donc il y a toujours
Modric qui peut jouer jusqu'à 72 ans va
voilà mais avec dal leur entraîneur leur
sélectionneur qui là c'est un peu le
Didier Deschamps croate ils ont toujours
des résultats ils ont pas non plus un
réservoir qui qui est colossal mais en
revanche il y a une a une vraie rigueur
et une vraie continuité alors la
Slovénie est tombe avec le Danemark et
l'Angleterre et qui va tomber avec la
France ce sera donc et ben les Pays-Bas
les Pays-Bas on le disait c'était
l'équipe à éité pour la France et ben
voilà France Autriche Pays-Bas ça
commence doucement à ressembler à un
groupe beaucoup moins abordable et bah
et voilà on disait Espagne croix si
c'était laaffiche du premier tour avant
Angleterre danemarque et ben non
maintenant c'est France Pays-Bas alors
je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est que
on a battu les les Néerlandais deux fois
en en phase éliminatoire de de du
championnat d'Europe mais euh il faut
savoir que les Pays-Bas à chaque fois
alors je pense au premier match au au
Stade de France il y avait eu un
problème avec avec certains joueurs il y
avait eu beaucoup de beaucoup de
forfaits et pareil au match retour au au
Pays-Bas à Amsterdam il y a quelques
semaines où les Français c'étaient
s'étaient imposés notamment grâce à un
doublé de de Kylian Mbappé il y avait
beaucoup d'absents il y avait pas de
paill enfin il manquait vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de monde donc c'est
difficile de dire que on a survolé et on
a vraiment finalement mis de côté les
Pays-Bas assez facilement euh serait pas
finalement relaté la la vérité les
Pays-Bas vont vont débarquer en
Allemagne avec une toute autre équipe et
et là c'est l'épouvantail c'est vraiment
le l'équipe qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
éviter si on se retrouve avec l'Italie
au au au 4e chapeau on aura vraiment le
entre guillemets le groupe de la mort
parce que on se répète mais les deux les
deux premiers sont qualifiés et après ce
sont les quatre meilleurs troisè alors
c'est la Slovaquie c'est la Slovaquie
qui est tombé avec la Belgique et la la
Roumanie et la République tchèque qui
tombe avec la Turquie et le Portugal par
contre nos amis les Belges ils passent
plutôt un bon tirage au sort pour
l'instant Slovaquie Roumanie dans sont
assez tranquill ils sont assez
tranquilles du côté de Bruxelles là ils
sont plutôt pas mal avec avec la
Slovaquie avec la Roumanie euh ils sont
plutôt plutôt sereins pour le pour le
premier tour ça c'est certain alors
alors on va vous faire un petit récap
avant les les groupes qui sont tirés
donc dans le groupe a l'Allemagne la
Hongrie l'Écosse dans le groupe B
l'Espagne l'Albanie la Croatie dans le
groupe C Angleterre danemarque dès le
premier tour donc on le disait la
Slovénie avec eux euh dans le groupe D
France Autriche Pays-Bas et le groupe E
Belgique Roumanie Slovaquie et groupe F
Portugal Turquie République tchèque et
on va bientôt découvrir qui on va avoir
dans ce dans ce fameux groupe dans cette
dans
cette excusez-moi cette 4e équipe
ensuite sachant qu'on connaitt que trois
équipes on le disait puisque il y aura
ensuite les vainqueurs des play-offs de
la Ligue A de la Ligue B de la Ligue C
on n'est pas rentré dans les détails
forcément parce que c'est un système
qu'on assez compliqué qu d'heure voilà
un petit quart d'heure et on va alors
que alors je suis assez surpris je vous
avoue parce que ce tirage au sort va
très très vite par contre parce que j'ai
je me rappelle de tirage au sort qui
mettait beaucoup plus de temps à se
décanter et ben pourquoi pas là non mais
là pour le coup si on fait un petit
recap vous l'avez fait à travers les les
différents groupes à l'instanté on
attend le 4e chapeau parce que forcément
quand vous allez avoir l'Italie qui va
être reversé dans tel ou tel groupe ça
sera une une couleur différentes mais là
les groupes les plus délicats avec des
guillemets on a quand même la France
avec France Pays-Bas Autriche en groupe
D après je mettrai aussi le le groupe B
groupe C où c'est un peu un peu kifkif
avec l'Espagne et la Croatie qui qui
paraissent au-dessus enfin même qui pas
paraissent mais qui qui sont au-dessus
de l'Albanie il y aura BAGAR
espagne-chroatie pour la première place
et en groupe C on a l'Angleterre qui
aura quand même fort faire avec avec le
Danemark dans une moindre mesure la
Slovénie mais les anglais sont quand
même assez favoris de ce ce groupe là et
on a des chanceux on a les les Allemands
alors après on l'a dit mais les
Allemands sont pas en grande forme mais
ils affrontent l'Hongrie et l'Écosse
c'est c'est plutôt abordable on dira ça
et puis après vous avez la Belgique qui
est assez tranquille face à la Roumanie
la Slovaquie en revanche oui Portugal
Portugal c'est pareil ils ont quand même
fait une super super série
d'éliminatoire ils ont ils ont ils ont
gagné t leurs match Ronaldo là aussi on
parlait de Modric mais mais c'est pareil
éternel il continue de il continue de
marquer but sur but il y a quand même de
très très beaux joueurs au Portugal on
pense notamment à Bernardo Silva qui est
quasiment le meilleur milieu de terrain
en Europe côté portugais mais aussi avec
Manchester City et là on va enchaîner
avec le le chapeau 4 là donc là c'est
parti et pour l'équipe de France il faut
éviter l'Italie alors c'est la Suisse
qui est tombée pour le groupe a donc
nous avons Allemagne Hongrie Écosse et
Suisse en fait il faut que le soit
l'Italie tombe très vite soit elle tombe
très tard pour l'instant l'Italie et ben
justement voilà oh alors le groupe B le
groupe B le groupe B Espagne almanie
Croatie Italie vous vouliz un groupe de
la mort le voilà donc c'est bon on l'a
donc là pour les supporters espagnols
croate italien il va falloir se ruer sur
les places qui seront mis en vente dans
quelques jours on sait déjà qu'il y a
pas mal de places notamment plus d'un
million de de tickets qui ont été vendus
mais à la suite de ce tirage au sort
chaque fédération aura des places
disponibles et là on sait que ce groupe
là Italie Croatie Espagne ça va être
assez extraordinaire au premier tour de
l'Euro forcément forcément on imagine
les pauvres petits albanais au milieu de
tout ça qui vont devoir réussir mais on
avait dit la même chose des desent des
faire valoir là pour le
coup les Hongrois avaient quand même
bien réussi eux sur enfin même s'il
avait terminé le dernier du groupe mais
ils avaient ils avaient rapporté deux
matchs nuls euh là c'est la Serbie qui
vient être tirée dans le groupe C donc
Angleterre Danemark Slovénie Serbie et
donc on va voir donc dans le pour le
pour la France nous allons voir qui va
être tiré pour la France mais ce sera un
vainqueur de play-off donc des
vainqueurs de de de ligue donc ce sera
on ne connaîtra pas encore la l'équipe
exacte qui jouera contre la
France et alors qu'elle elle est tirée
en ce moment et bien ce sera les
play-off a alors attendez je reprends
mon petit tableau les play-off a nous
aurons droit donc au pays de Gal à la
Finlande à la Pologne ou à l'Estonie bah
c'était les meilleures équipes
finalement possible de ces play-offs on
a par exemple la Pologne que la France a
joué en Coupe du monde en en 8e de
finale exactement polonne Gal Finlande
et Estonie en gros c'est Gal Finlande
donc le vainqueur de Gal Finlande
affrontera Pologne ou eston et ce
vainqueur de de de cette petite finale
entre guillemets aura le plaisir
d'êtreeversé dans le groupe avec la
France l'Autriche et et les Pays-Bas
donc très sincèrement Vincent là on va
pas on va pas s'enflammer mais on a un
groupe vraiment vraiment abordable on
l'a dit les deux les deux premiers sont
qualifiés les quatre meilleurs 3è aussi
l'équipe de France est est la grande
favorite de ce de ce groupe là attention
au Pays-Bas on l'a dit aussi ce sera pas
la même équipe qu'on a affronté en 2023
dans les illiminatoires de l'euro euh
l'Autriche moindre mesure et puis après
on attendra de voir pour le pour le
barragisme mais mais il fallait éviter
l'Italie et et on l'a fait et et
là-dessus l'équipe de France gu Stéphan
va rentrer tranquillement sur la Côte
d'Azur assez satisfait Didier Deschamp
de son canapé du côté là aussi de la
Côte d'Azur parce qu'ils habitent pas
très loin l'un de l'autre sera aussi
satisfait même s'ils vont dire euh je
vous fais déjà les discours des
sélectionneurs on a des il faut il faut
Gal au rendez-vous on respecte tout le
monde ce sera délicat la vérité
d'aujourd'hui est pas celle dans
quelques mois on connaît le on connaît
le topo mais en tout cas l'équipe de
France a un tirage plutôt plutôt
abordable il y aura match avec les
Pays-Bas après vous êtes dans un
championnat d'Europe he vous pouvez pas
non plus affronter des équipes de 4e
zone tout le temps il faut aussi sortir
les muscles et et là ça va être
important je trouve que finalement ce
groupe là est est idéal dans le sens où
il y a quand même une grosse affiche
avec les Pays-Bas donc il y a pas de
quoi s'endormir et et après derrière il
faudra faire le boulot contre contre
l'Autriche et puis après contre un un
débarragiste mais mais ce sera ce sera
intéressant bien sûr effectivement bon
alors le tir sort vient de se terminer
donc on va vous faire groupe par groupe
pour un peu aussi faire quelques petits
pronosti même si nous sommes à un peu
plus de 6 mois de la compétition vous
l'avez compris Allemagne Écosse Hongrie
Suisse pour le groupe
a Baptiste c'est pour l'Allemagne et la
Suisse au premier pour les deux
premières places normalement alors après
il faut voir avec avec l'Écosse mais
mais normalement les Allemands mais le
souci c'est qu'aujourd'hui les Allemands
sont sont vraiment très très moyens ils
enchaînent les déconvenus ils font des
ils font des mauvais matchs nagelsman va
d' arriver donc franchement c'est un
gros point d'interrogation l'Allemagne
ça peut être un gros four être éliminé
dès le premier tour de son euro mais là
quand on voit l'adversité ce serait
vraiment un fiasco et indigne de d'une
sélection comme l'Allemagne donc oui
effectivement l'Allemagne est favorite
mais mais aujourd'hui c'est c'est
vraiment délicat de de dire les
Allemands vont faire ça ça en en
championnat d'Europe parce qu'ils sont
ils sont vraiment en grande difficulté
Salomon dans les commentaires qui nous
dit l'Allemagne n'est pas en pleine
forme tout est possible effectivement
vous n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à nous
dire ce que vous avez pensé de ce tirage
au sort donc ça c'était pour le groupe a
donc le groupe B on le disait groupe de
la mort donc Espagne Croatie Italie
Albanie
oui bah ça pour le coup ça c'est un
groupe qui est extraordinaire entre
l'Espagne la Croatie l'Italie l'Albanie
ça va être ça va être difficile ils vont
ils vont jouer les les fire varloir mais
euh mais mais je mets je mets l'Espagne
qui est quand même audessus après il y
aura match entre Croatie et et Italie
les Croates on dit tout à l'heure petit
pays mais nation extraordinaire de de
football avec des joueurs fabuleux comme
Modric notamment mais pas seulement
dalis l'entraîneur qui qui est là depuis
très longtemps et qui saura finalement
bien mener aussi la destinée des Croates
très franchement il y a match hein mais
même même Espagne Croatie je peux pas
dire que l'Espagne va écraser ce ce
groupe là donc il y aura vraiment match
et et derrière ça va faire une belle
bagarre aussi pour la 2uxe et 3e place
donc on a hâte d'être pour voir ce ce
groupe B h et on se rappelle que
l'Espagne avait é quand même assez passé
à côté de ça de sa coupe du monde
l'Italie n'était pas et la Croatie avit
quand même terminé 3e le groupe C
Angleterre Danemark donc c'est la
demi-finale du dernier Euro et la
Slovénie et la serie oui là l'Angleterre
paraît vraiment a-dessus de au-dessus
des autres et derrière très franchement
je vois bien il y aura match entre
Danemark Slovénie et Serbie mais les
anglais sont sont vraiment audessus
quand on voit la la génération qu'ils
ont avec les Saka les Kane Rice et et
compagnie c'est vraiment une très très
grosse équipe c'est une des favorites
finalement du de cette euro donc les
Anglais en encore une fois on va pas on
va pas insulter le niveau du Danemark de
la Slovénie et de la Serbie mais les
anglais sont vraiment les gros favoris
de ce groupe C dans le groupe D donc on
disait France Autriche Pays-Bas France 1
Pays-Bas 2 et après ça dépend aussi
beaucoup de l'équipe qui se qui se
retrouveent contre nous mais ça devrait
être quoi le la Pologne ou ou le pays de
Gal plutôt oui dans oui ça ça va jouer
je pense entre entre Pologne et pays de
Gal mais je regardais juste au niveau du
du calendrier euh il faut savoir que les
Français commenceront contre contre
l'Autriche le 16 juin euh ça sera leur
le premier match de de pooule après on
aura le match contre les contre les
Pays-Bas le 21 juin et on terminera la
le premier tour contre le les barragiste
enfin le barragiste le 25 juin donc en
en 10 jours on sera on sera fixé mais
mais c'est plutôt un calendrier aussi
qui est favorable dans le sens où vous
allez pouvoir affronter tout de suite
l'Autriche qui peut vous qui peut vous
embêter en tout cas qui a toute toutes
les qualités pour pour vous embêter ça
fait un premier match pour monter en
puissance et puis après derrière deuxème
match contre l'Autriche et contre les
Pays-Bas pardon et si vous êtes déjà 6
points au bout de deux matchs contre les
baragis vous pouvez déjà être certain
que didchamp fera jouer l'équipe B s'ils
sont vraiment certain d'être qualifié et
d'être d'être premier dans ce groupe
donc au niveau du calendrier c'est là
aussi je trouve assez assez favorable
pour did Deschamp dans le côté monter en
puissance et et comment je vais mener ma
barque pour pour ce premier tour de
l'Euro et ça on sait que pour lui c'est
c'est c'est très important à chaque fois
qu'il a fait des dans dans toutes les
compétitions d'arriver à faire monter
finalement en puissance son équipe c'est
quelque chose qui revient beaucoup dans
ce qu'il dit ben pour lui c'est c'est
important et et primordial parce que il
sait très bien qu' un euro alors premier
tour il faut expédier les affaires
courantes mais après derrière euh
forcément c'est c'est les matchs coups
et il souvient énormément il l'a pas
digéré dit leschamp même si on sort
d'une finale de Coupe du Monde il a pas
digéré cette défaite en 8e de finale
contre l'Autriche on souvient l'équipe
de France on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais
oui contre la TR contre la Suisse pardon
on souvient l'équipe de France au
premier tour il y a il a il y a plus de
2 ans Allemagne Portugal Hongrie ils
avaient bataillé jusqu'au bout Didier
deschan avait pas pu faire tourner ça
l'avait agacé ils avaient perdu beaucoup
d'influx physiquement aussi c'était
c'était deux gros matchs et le troisème
c'était surtout un gros cagnard ils
étaient arrivés contre la Suisse il y
avait plus rien dans les jambes beaucoup
de blessés on se souvient Adrien rabio
avait été latéral gauche enfin défense à
5 des problèmes avec coman avec avec
rabio avec Pogba pendant le match donc
c'était vraiment un non match des Bleus
Deschamp et et tous ces joueurs le
savent donc le premier tour je trouve
est quand même ultra favorable à
l'équipe de France en dehors des des
Pays-Bas mais le fait de jouer un
barragiste et l'Autriche plus le le
calendrier on le disait avec France
Autriche le 16 juin France Pays-Bas le
21 et et match contre le barragiste le
25 c'est plutôt favorable on va pas se
plaindre on va pas se plaindre
effectivement dans les commenta on nous
parle de l'Écosse qui va poter des
problèmes de jeu avec son style de jeu à
l'Allemagne l'Écosse qui était dans en
qualification et qui a battu notamment
la Norvège qui a empêché la Norvège der
lingaland Martino degard de se de se
qualifier donc une une une nation à
surveiller forcément même si elle semble
en dessous de l'Allemagne et de la
Suisse dans le groupe E Belgique
Slovaquie Roumanie et ensuite vous
choisissez entre l'Ukraine Israël
Islande et la Bosnie ça ça ressemble
plutôt au groupe facile entre guillemets
ah ça fait un peu promenade de santé
pour les pour les Belges au premier tour
je vois pas comment s'ils ont vraiment
leur leur niveau euh comment ils peuvent
pas terminer à la première place de ce
groupe hein franchement il y a il y a
pas photo avec la Roumanie la Slovaquie
et le barragiste pour moi c'est c'est
une problème de santé pour les Belges au
premier tour h et donc le dernier groupe
ce sera Turquie Portugal République
tchèck et une équipe à choisir entre la
geéorgie le Luxembourg la Grèce et le
Kazakhstan promade de santé à venir
aussi pour le Portugal bah ils sont déjà
les Portugais comme on disait au au tout
début de la retransmission c'est que
avec les Français et et les Anglais pour
moi c'est les trois meilleures équipes
d'Europe actuellement et et là oui
Turquie moindre mesure République
tchèque et puis le barragis en plus ils
prennent le barragis vous l'avez dit
Vincent de la voie donc d'une des
nations entre guillemets les plus
faibles de la Ligue des Nations je pense
que les Grecs peuvent sortir quand même
parce que vous avez le Kazakhstan enfin
bon c'est quand même pas des foots de
guerre donc oui les Portugais sont sont
largement favoris de ce groupe F bien
entendu il y a la Géorgie mais je vais
pas vous demander de me donner les noms
des des joueurs parce que même si vous
les connaissez
imprononçable après on on va prendre un
peu de temps mais ça c'est c'est un peu
plus compliqué effectivement merci
beaucoup Baptiste Desf en tout cas
d'avoir été allez-y allez-y juste
c'était là c'est de la projection donc
on est plus sur du foot fiction mais
l'équipe de France donc groupe D s'ils
sortent premier les Français du groupe D
ils affronteront le le deuxè du groupe
du groupe F donc ça reste quand même
aussi en en 8e de finale un un tableau
qui semble plutôt plutôt abordable si
les Portugais font le boulot vous
affrontez la ou la République tchèque en
en 8e de finale c'est c'est c'est plutôt
abordable et ce serait le le 2 juillet à
lachig effectivement euh il faudra il
faudra être solide forcément pour
réussir ça et ensuite on croisera avec
le premier du groupe E si je me trompe
pas premier du groupe E donc ce sera la
Belgique a priori ça pourrait être on
pourrait tomber sur la Belgique dès les
dès les quarts de finale la Belgique on
le dit sort du pas une super coupe du
monde mais qui a une nouvelle génération
qui monte aussi exactement et après on
serait dans le tableau alors après là on
est vraiment sur du foot fiction parce
que tout ce qui se passe là ça se
passera pas au mois de juin juillet mais
en revanche on serait dans la partie de
tableau si tout est respecté la logique
est respecté on serait quand même dans
la partie de tableau des Anglais en en
quart de finale
oui oui on serait on serait avec les
Anglais et puis on pourrait aussi être
avec 2è du groupe a 2è du groupe B donc
si les Allemands se ratent ils peuvent
être là aussi ou sinon ça peut être
Espagne Croatie ou Italie donc on a
quand même une les 8è de finale ça
serait abordable quart de finale contre
le contre les Belges faudra voir la
suite mais oui oui après B de toute
façon c'est normal hein vous arrivez en
demi-finale il faudra aussi se frotter
aux plus grandes nations européennes et
on se rappelle la Coupe du monde alors
les les Anglais vont avoir sûrement un
peu envie de de prendre le revanche
après après le quart de finale puisque
c'était quand même l'un des matchs de la
Coupe du monde avec le plus gros niveau
technique on s'en rappelle Baptiste
franceangleterre ah oui oui on est passé
tout prêt très franchement si Harry Kane
met son penalty il y a peut-être une
autre destinée pour l'équipe de France
pour l'Angleterre on s'était fait
énormément bousculer notamment au milieu
de terrain les Anglais ont ont une super
équipe on l'a dit avec avec Kane en chef
de film mais pas seulement que ce soit
au milieu derrière c'est vraiment une
très très belle équipe les Anglais après
ils ont une éthqu de de loser dans le
sens où ils gagnent ils gagnent jamais
une grande compétition européenne et
mondiale on verra il va va bien falloir
qu'ils ent gagne une un moment ou un
autre mais mais non ça promet ça promet
en tout cas on est on a hâte va y avoir
un beau premier tour notamment un bel
affrontement contre les Pays-Bas et puis
après derrière un 8e de finale qui peut
paraître abordable la Belgique peut-être
en quart et puis bon bah les Anglais ou
les allemands espagnols ça c'est du foot
fiction on verra pour la suite mais en
tout cas oui non ça on a ditê on l'a dit
c'est 14 juin 14 juillet et et l'équipe
de France fait partie des bah des
grandes favorites de de cette
compétition européenne oui et puis
l'équipe de France on en parle aussi
parce que l'équipe qui qui sera à l'EUR
alors on la connaît pas elle sera
dévoilée
forcément un mois avant la la
compétition mais pour autant on on
commence par contre à connaître bien les
contours de cette équipe ah bah très
sincèrement on connaît 97 98 %
finalement des contours de cette équipe
l' des 23 qui sera dévoilé par did
Deschamps mi mai euh comme d'habitude et
puis après l'équipe de France qui se
rassemblera fin mai du côté de de
Clairefontaine juste au niveau du un
petit point calendrier Vincent euh au
niveau de l'équipe de France il y a il y
a un rassemblement donc au mois de mars
où il y aura un match contre le bah
justement contre contre les Allemands à
dessine du côté de du côté de Lyon ce
sera le 23 mars on aura un match à
Marseille le 26 match amical et après
donc il y aura la liste des bleus des 23
mi- Maai rassemblement fin mai dans la
première quinzaine du mois de juin il y
aura un match amical à Bordeaux et et
ames et après il sera temps de de partir
pour l'Allemagne avec le premier match
contre l'Autriche le le 16 juin mais
pour revenir à votre question sur le sur
la liste oui on connaît quasiment
quasiment tous les joueurs très
franchement il y a il y a très très peu
d'incertitude euh au niveau de l'équipe
équipe de France sans rentrer dans dans
tous les détails il y aura peut-être un
petit doute sur savoir si Christopher
enkunku pourra rentrer dans la rotation
on sait que Didier Deschamps et son
staff l'apprécie mais il sort d'une
blessure au genou à Chelsea on verra
comment il va récupérer tout ça en début
d'année avec les blouses mais mais sinon
que ce soit au milieu de terrain
dernièrement
le le petit waren remry voilà 17 ans qui
arrivé en équipe de France qui a fait
que quelques quelques minutes de jeu
contre gibratar mais salut a suffit pour
marquer déjà un but et puis marquer les
esprits lui il y a des chances qu'il lu
soit aussi il y aura un doute sur Ngolo
Kanté s'il y a pas écat tombe de joueurs
au milieu de terrain n goolé sera pas
dans la liste des 23 revanche il a UNEC
tombe parce qu'on le rappelle hein
encore une fois ce qu'on dit là
aujourd'hui ça peut être balayé d'un
revers demain au mois de au mois de mai
on se souvient quand même pour la
dernière Coupe du monde que l'équipe de
France avait été privée de de Pogba de
Kanté de Kim
pemé de Benzema bien entendu de kunku
aussi donc il av eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'absen ce qui avait permis de révéler
aussi notamment un Randal colomoani mais
mais là si on si on en parle aujourd'hui
et qu'on s'arrête à l'instant oui Didier
Deschamp il a quasiment 100 % de ses
joueurs dans dans sa liste des 23 h
alors Mike dans les commentaires qui
nous dit qu'il voit le titre pour les
Pays-Bas puisque en 88 les Pays-Bas
avaient été sacré à l'Euro en Allemagne
c'était passé en Allemagne et CIT
lesays-bas qui avaient gagné moi j'avais
une autre une autre stat à vous donner
c'est moi je me rappelle très bien des
Pays-Bas dans le même groupe que la
France c'était à l'Euro 2000 il me
semble exactement non non mais les
Pays-Bas de toute façon ça reste une des
une des grandes nations on peut pas dire
que c'est facile d'affronter les
Pays-Bas en phase de poule d'un
championnat d'Europe et et on l'a répété
plusieurs fois ce soir mais c'est que ça
sera pas du tout la même équipe qu'on va
affronter au au mois de juin et qu'on a
pu voir en 2023 ils avaient eu beaucoup
d'absen il y a quand même une une belle
génération on pense au au nouveau comme
le petit jaavy Simons qui joue au
parisgermain qui est prêté en Allemagne
devant il y a de paill on a van DJ enfin
il y a quand même beaucoupoup beaucoup
de de grands éléments qui jouent dans
les plus grands clubs européens donc
c'est une très belle équipe aussi les
les Pays-Bas il y aura BAGAR pour la
première place avec l'équipe de France
et donc on suivra ça pour cette euro qui
commencera dans un peu plus de 6 mois
merci beaucoup Baptiste des pr d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui Merci à VOUS
du Figaro d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre sur le site ainsi que sur
Youtube moi je vous dis à bientôt pour
Nau live sur Figaro live et retrouver
tous les articles sur le site du Figaro
pour décrypter ce tirage au sort bonne
soirée sur le
Figaro